it's moving day
in manchester tens of thousands of
students
are heading back to university after a
summer of uncertainty
a new beginning in a new home for second
year students
alex beth and molly i mean obviously
it's really exciting to be back together
but
because of where we are we are a bit
apprehensive about like seeing people
and like what sort of
rules we should stick to and but it's
really nice to be back together again
so there's eight of us in total so
hopefully when they start letting other
households back inside together then
should probably be those guys maybe a
couple of people but apart from that
will be careful
i'm definitely excited to see my friends
because it's been like just me and my
family for so long
but yeah i'm not gonna go crazy
obviously student social life
in this city will be different it
remains an area of concern for the
government
with high coronavirus cases and the
notorious
nightlife here is now non-existent
it means house parties are on the cards
first day back
and these students are already planning
a gathering i think we're definitely
going to do things in moderation like
because we're definitely going to be
sensible about it like we're not just
going to invite the whole neighbourhood
round
public health experts say the return to
university
is a critical moment in the coronavirus
pandemic
this is going to be an incredible
challenge um
not only for a higher education sector
but equally to find a way
for young people to socialize going
forward that doesn't put
older people vulnerable people at risk
but despite the concerns and the threat
of the spread of coronavirus
some students are prepared to take the
risk just because you're in a
city with you know everyone around and
it's easy to give into that temptation
of just meeting up with people again so
yeah house parties are definitely going
to be like the normal thing now
i think because clubs are shut and
obviously no one's done anything for so
long
that everyone's just kind of bored of
being stuck inside and it doesn't feel
so serious having you know 20 people in
a house
i think with thousands of people coming
here soon like i don't know it's gonna
be hard to control as well because
people's gonna do what they want so i
don't know
students have been hit hard by the
consequences of this pandemic
they now see themselves in the spotlight
being blamed for the rise in cases
many feel a responsibility has been
forced upon them
whether they comply could make a vital
difference
in rasheed sky news manchester